Ah! What a confusing look.
Hi guys, my name is Grace Helbig, if you did not know, now you know, your life is different now.
I went on my twitter and asked you guys what kind of video did you want to see today and someone said
how to handle the morning after a
Valentine's day one-night stand? And that's a completely valid thing to want to know how handle. Though if you're watching this video right now
I'm sure you've already handled it. If you are still at or dealing with a one-night stand and you're watching this video...
Uhm, weird, but also, I hope this is helpful.
I've made videos like this in the past in which I think the answers to a lot of life's difficult questions can be found
in music. So, here are three different ways that you can handle a valentine's day one-night stand
if the one I stand is at your house. AKA
Here's how they use music to kick out a one-night stand. First method is to use pure, raw, unadulterated
honesty. It is direct, and it's no bullshit. Here's how it could go down:
Good morning, beautiful
Shit.
What's wrong?
Okay, I
won't lie to you. I have no idea who you are.
-It's fine, it's Steve
-But I do know that know that
you're not the one for me.
-Whoa?
-Oh! And now my bedsheets smell like you.
-Yeah they do, what do they smell like?
-Shit.
There's a hope that's waiting for you in the dark.
-A what?
-I just called you a lyft, Steve is here. He's driving a Honda Civic.
Oh okay, yeah, cool. That's cool.
Wait a minute, can--
-There's no stopping
Wait, are your Capricorn?
-No.
-Then like I said, there's no stopping
The second method is be really passive-aggressive by way of pretending that you're crazy. Here's how that could go down:
Shit.
Good morning, beautiful.
-I feel it coming.
-What's coming?
-You see, I've got issues.
-What?
-I feel it coming.
-These friends keep talking way too much.
-What friends?
-The friends inside my head.
-Okay.
-It's so cold out here.
-What is happening to me--
-I do not know.
-I feel it coming.
-What?
-Where?
-I feel it coming.
-Why?
-Uh, oh. Water under the bridge.
-Hmm?
-I just pissed myself.
-Okay.
Wait, how do we--
-There's no stopping.
And the third method is just pretending you have lockjaw.
Good morning, beautiful.
-Mmm
-What did you say?
-Mmm.
-I can't understand.
-Are you?
-Mmm.
-You're saying my dick is huge?
-My dick is small?
-Mmm
-My dick is huge?
-Mmm.
-Okay, I'm gonna go...
-Mmm
-Did you say my dick is h--
-There's no stopping.
Well, there you go! There are some of my methods for handling the morning after
not only a valentine's day one-night stand, but, you know, any one-night stand you might have. I hope these are really helpful,
how was your Valentine's day?
Cool, great, awesome. If you liked this video give it a thumbs up and click this button to subscribe to this YouTube channel
cuz, you know, we-- I put thought into things sometimes, like this outfit. I don't know.